immediate an aggressive reading they're
the ones have you're my vessel
damn this is the fastest glad that'll
never happen moment in TV since history
this opening recap sequence lasts for a
minute and a half I guess someone on the
writing team thought that we needed to
see these important moments like this
refrigerator in the road yeah it was a
major turning point the story for me
also if this series of images is
supposed to get me caught up or refresh
my memory about what's happened in any
way this series of images has failed
furthermore when they played Kansas this
carry on wayward son which will be a
great song one day when I'm 57 but not
now
on April 21st 1967 a hundred millionth
GM vehicle rolled off the line narration
of a story being written about two
characters within a book within a show
at this point the show has become the
metafiction that normal metafiction
vomits out when it can't contain itself
anymore
three days later another car rolled off
that same line no one gave two craps
about her god dammit don't you try and
make me feel bad for a car don't you
make it a little person with feelings
car lights are nice girls aren't smiles
and we have to leave old Betty for a new
car we hurt her feelings because she'll
find a new family am I happy Ross free
life where a young marine bought her on
impulse that is after a little advice
from a friend
if by friend you mean a man who looks
exactly like his future son because he
is this future son but oddly that is
never noticed then yes I guess that's
where this story begins and here's where
it ends
wait we're done packing up people time
to get on with our day this is what you
want I'll back your play that's the last
thing I thought you'd ever say might be
now I will take 30 more minutes for Dean
to say his last words to his brother but
only for the season because Lucifer
knows this show dramatizes the hell out
of everything and watching out for you
it's my job you know first notes of
dramatic piano and a hint of emotion and
a gravelly voice skipped I let him out
but you don't you've got a goddamn angel
from heaven on your team and a family
friend / father figure who would gladly
die before anything ever happened to you
but it's a finale so let's put the coin
to see which brother has to sacrifice
themselves this season I had a bad
feeling about this cliche so you gotta
promise me something okay
anything promise me you'll keep your
eyes on the goddamn Road
promise me no really Dean look at the
road while you drive
I'm still sending you you crazy bastard
oh you don't say Detroit Michigan II I
mean it's only been mentioned four times
in the past three minutes what about
Detroit Devils in Detroit Detroit jump
your bones in Detroit you may as well
put exactly where you think we should be
as the title card Sam still human right
and while I don't drink blood often I'm
pretty sure there isn't a human on earth
who could guzzle down for milk jugs of
demon blood without throwing up
immediately the devil doesn't know or
care what kind of car the boys drive
neither does this viewer chock-full of
Ovaltine are we what good does it do Sam
to give anything away here those demon
bodyguards weren't going to cause any
kind of problem clearly so while I play
his hand so early I know you have the
Rings Sam by the time book 14 on the
Lord of the Rings series rolling around
Tolkien really ran out of ideas
Sam lines as in negotiation about more
rings with Sauron the third geez fiddle
of gold against your souls as I Lucifer
limericks so he knows it doesn't change
anything Sam we don't have any other
choice no yes so burn my supernatural
fanpage sir just Sam has to give the
double permission to possess him which
honestly let's send that first because
it's the devil for Christ's sake but
that being said Sam already gave him
permission right I want to say yes so
this whole bargaining chip Lucifer is
using really doesn't matter he could
have already been wearing his Sam suit
and on his way to Sears to shot the
Sunday sales this would be a good time
for Dean to push Sam right I mean
everything has been building up to this
moment this has to happen or tell fire
and brimstone for the rest of the world
so why is Dean even taking a chance here
you know me all wrong Cal I'm talking to
the Sam in the mirror Oh
such anger young Skywalker Star Wars
references I've been waiting for you
for a long long time I get Sammy has
some powers and whatnot but am I the
only one that finds it humorous that the
doubles big plans all rely on Sam
Winchester I'm inside your grapefruit
Sam dude taking Sam's body and putting
him inside a mirror is one thing but
practicing sex on his fresh produce is
across the line in real life I have yet
to see an electronics company fill their
window displays with easily Sun damaged
televisions let alone set them all to
err news channels and then wire them for
sound so passers-by can stop and be
informed of important exposition as they
walk about town otherwise said as this
is some bull I suggest we imbibe copious
quantities of alcohol just wait for the
inevitable blast wave Castiel would be
my man over a TV sits that was never
much hope to begin with I don't know
what else to do
everyone's shocked that this show made
it five seasons somehow makes it into
this episode Sam used to insist on
honest work but now he hustles pool the
color of Sammy mr. Specter no Chuck
why do [ __ ] in shows answer a phone
like they have clairvoyance and they
always say something that is super
embarrassing to someone who turns out
isn't that person at all nobody else's a
phone like this Dick's angels are
keeping a top secret very hush-hush
crap I saw it anyway perks would be a
profit it's crazy Chuck always knows all
the regardless of whether he's a prophet
or not he would almost have to be God to
have this kind of knowledge
tomorrow high noon on High Noon you say
high western ass noon
well why wouldn't it be you're gonna do
something stupid you got that look
nah man that's just his face you ready
as I'll ever be
so all the prophecies become realized a
brother fighting brother and the Angels
took the skins of two brothers to have
this brotherly war huh brother yep
make sure you get your own personalized
Def Leppard soundtrack going before you
attempt to thwart Michael and Lucifer
from killing each other it's not like
there's a timetable or a world at stake
sorry mind it up do something cliche did
you just Molotov my brother with holy
fire better question if the fire was
holy and Michael is only then why would
it hurt him wouldn't unholy fire be more
likely to kill an angel and he's
feel the snapper here bones every single
one that is far too many bones to watch
being broken hey happy sunshine beam
penetrates the devil's hold on Sam
revealing a full minute and 15 seconds
of memories that release Lucifer's hold
on his mind did I get that right okay
iconic but how Lucifer said the deal was
for one round and he beat you I'm
getting the feeling that I really can't
take anything seriously so don't take
this too seriously also a good thing
Lucifer not only didn't destroy the
Horseman's rings but he kept them in
Sam's pocket why would he do this why
yes sir you got that's a nice compliment
but no although I do believe he brought
me back God ex machina so just God I
guess hey remember those super
meaningful deaths of major characters
that Dean had to witness and Sam will
have to live with their blood on his
hands for the rest of his life
well the backpal endings are hard
supernatural narration brought to you by
Stephen King you got what you asked for
Dean no paradise no hell just more the
same in hindsight probably you should
have asked for a paradise at the very
least Dean didn't want Cass to save him
no one who's heard make your own kind of
music would ever say that but he isn't
gonna do either because he made a
promise did either
promise me nope so what's it all that up
to well from what I can tell it's a load
of Lawson 40 minutes of disappointment
endings are hard but then again nothing
ever really ends does it
considering we have 10 more seasons of
the show or I guess not
I'm a fan of mad make sure you click
that Bell icon but clicking the little
bell icon is how you make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
so click it you know I am Lucifer I have
so many names I don't know if we got a
snowball's chance but this is our you
fight him tooth and nail you understand
I don't want them to gain another yard
you Brits Oh like chock-full of Ovaltine
are we o morado hmm
come on review apart from the inside out
do you understand me I will rip your
soul out daddy I want you to be happy
Sam I don't want your life